let's go to Peter hey now I know hey so
my wife is expecting our first son I'm
wrapping my brain around whether or not
to get a circumcision I feel your pain
dude I tell you the truth I never had a
son so I didn't I didn't have to
confront this Howard if you talk to most
of the guys on the staff who are
uncircumcised at one point or another
they've had issues whether it be with
infections yeah but a lot of the guys on
our staff our animals I mean they now
fred is a gentleman and fred does
maintain his penis and he claims he does
not have a problem only one time was
there a ripping oh I may be sick when I
should have zagged and a cat or a little
bit other than that
smooth sailing right and as long keep it
clean you don't have a problem so
haven't you had trouble with infections
in your life yes I had eczema a few
times I've had red spots sometimes in
the morning I take a leak I get dizzy
from the smell that's wafting up it does
the cheese and the stink that could
develop there is horrible do you wash
I wash Daly Robin but if I skip a shower
I could kill a cat with this I mean
Chris Wilding we've had private
conversations about this he says it's a
nightmare with the smell if I jerk off
the night before and I fall asleep even
if I wipe it doesn't matter if I go to
use the bathroom the next day you'll get
like a fish style odor it'll hit you
sure play that logic to women well I
don't want to be with women either no
but I'm saying that maybe they should
call off their vaginas if they smell a
little bit like if you take care of
yourself to myself I listen I came back
from a vacation in February where I
don't know I guess I was in wet bathing
suits or whatever I had such an issue
with my dick for months I was putting
creams I was seeing doctors I had to go
on FaceTime at one point during Kovac
and show the dermatologist my penis it
was a nightmare I put garlic on my [ __ ]
to get rid of the infections and smell I
mixed it with yogurt and garlic I put it
on my [ __ ] and then it got hot and all
the sugars from the yogurt got into the
head of my penis and my whole penis was
completely infected what doctor told you
to do that song no doctor Google Google
speaking of that odor
remember when Sal smeared his [ __ ]
cheese on Richards face it was bad right
Richard oh my god I've smelled roadkill
that's been sitting on a sunny road for
like 10 days and it's no better than
cells I didn't wash my penis for two
weeks oh my god I've never smelled
anything like it and I swear I have not
eaten ricotta cheese ricotta
I got a [ __ ] question for the guys now
I've seen tons of porno movies with guys
have uncircumcised [ __ ] I've never seen
a [ __ ] like Sal's it has so much skin
right I mean how does that happen he's a
free it looks like bell-bottom pants
dude it's the weirdest looking [ __ ]
[ __ ] I've ever seen in my life well
Peter the only thing I can tell you is
this you have a big decision to make
whether to circumcise your son in order
to help you now I will go around to the
panel and find out their final vote
Robin you are now about to give birth to
his son do you circumcised or not yes or
no that's all I'm looking for no Sal no
will no Chris yes I can't believe I'm
saying this Richard yes Fred
yeah I know no no circumcision Ronnie
yes Gary yes well there's your answer
who's counting yes Sabbath 5 to 4 I say
Peter get the best medical advice that
you possibly can
and make your decision don't listen to
these wackos
[Laughter]